amanda is in washington d.c hi amanda
how are you hi it's such a pleasure to
talk to you you too
what's up so I've got kind of an unusual
situation 14 years ago I attended
college and like most kids their parents
say they'll they'll pay for a chunk and
my parents did which was very kind of
them and then I would assume the rest my
rest came out to about $45,000 which was
a hard realization when I got done and
I'm actually still not done
unfortunately but so my parents got
divorced and my mom assumed the student
loan the $45,000 student loan no she she
she kept her she assumed what my parents
were gonna jointly pay a Parent PLUS
loan
yes exactly doing about 20 okay so that
was their cap for me and I thought that
was very very generous and then I just I
took on the rest of it so my husband I
have paid on about seventeen thousand
dollars down from the start and we've
been doing financial piece for two years
and just kind of you know praising the
program we've even taught the program
and we just we love it it's just been
such a blessing so every time we have a
little bit of success she reminds me
that she still has one of my student
loans and that once we get done with
ours we should probably start sending
her money and have you ever responded
and said mom that wasn't what you told
me we were going to do yes and she says
because finances have changed she feels
that it's unfair that we want to help
her after we become debt-free and it's
it's a lot of emotional chaos because my
husband and I are fighting hard to get
out from underneath this is the last bit
we've got about thirty thousand dollars
and we
what is your household income my husband
makes 117 and I homeschool our boys okay
and what is your mom like honestly I'm
not a hundred percent sure I think it's
around thirty thousand dollars a year
and what does your dad make he is out of
the picture completely and does not
assist with anything I know I got that
part but he also was in on the promise
to pay this yes she refuses to be in
contact with him do you know an ex do
you not have any contact with him no no
it's been over 10 years since we've had
any contact okay unfortunately that's
Rilke I mean it's not okay I'm sorry but
I mean okay all right well here's the
thing
your mom is emotionally
unreasonable because she's broke okay
she's breaking her word okay you didn't
make a you didn't make a contract with
her when you were 24 years old that said
I will pay mom thank you for the
generosity of Pete green to pick up
$20,000 of this but if it ever gets bad
you let me know and I'll pay it
that was never sad yeah and I mean we
were very were we have been extremely
diligent with the 45 we're whittling it
down as fast as we can I know I got that
and and the so the thing is this if you
give your mom $20,000 to pay this off
it'll be in a lump sum it will not go to
your mother it will go direct to the
student loan and it will be a little
later from now when you're in really
good shape and able to do that without
any strain because this is a charitable
gift okay it's not an obligation I
really appreciate that it's it's been
extremely stressful no the reason is she
she's a travel agent for guilt trips
okay and this isn't the only place she
violates boundaries oh yeah there's
other places no she
just tramples all over fences whenever
she wants and when it when it serves her
well whether it's with the grandkids or
whatever it is I mean she's not a person
she's not a person who has good
boundaries and the problem is this when
someone feels entitled to walk on your
property you follow me that's a boundary
right yeah yeah to cut across your yard
when someone feels entitled to do that
as if it's public ground and then you
tell them they can't then they usually
react pretty poorly yes and so it
creates a lot of strange yeah you can
expect her but listen the way she reacts
is her problem it's not your problem
okay cuz basically here's the truth from
what if for me what you told me you know
if you told me something wrong and
something's different but from what you
told me your mom made a promise that now
she's breaking because she's broke yes
and she's trying to make it out like
it's your fault and like you're a bad
daughter or a bad person or ungrateful
or something else if you don't give her
money yeah and she wants us to pay on
the interest to get the creditors off
her back and after taking her course
we're like it's just basically burning
money and my husband works hard now if
you guys choose to give her a $20,000
gift and pay this loan off you'll do it
in the lump sum and you'll pay it in
full after you have your emergency fund
in place okay yeah it's not it's not in
your baby this is not a baby step two
because it's not a personal obligation
just because she feels like it's an
obligation of yours doesn't make it an
obligation of yours
yeah after our loans are paid off we
want to start attacking retirement and
stuff like that because we're behind
well you're gonna be okay you're gonna
be okay and your husband is doing he's
got a good career and your mom doesn't
make much money she's broke so if you
want to help her that would be the place
to help her baby step three be and
beyond and but but in the meantime I
don't think you're ever gonna make her
happy
ever okay even when you pay this
because she's got to be something else
yeah she's got something else going on
all the time so just get over the
illusion that you know if I just pay
this at this dress I'll go away no cuz
she's gonna come up with something else
you know y'all are rich you ought to
send me $200 a month just because the
poor old lady can't get by over here
you'd think if I had a dollar and banned
all this money that she'd be grateful
into you remember when I took care of
her you'd think that no my lord
this isn't that if that's not how she's
saying it it's close it's yeah it's
there's a lot of health issues and
there's things that should be taken care
of that aren't and a lot of self
indulgences that shouldn't be happening
and we're definitely sacrificing too you
know for the betterment of our know what
I you know what I might do is I might
say mom I can't do this right now
and we've talked about it what we
decided to do is after we get out of
debt and get our emergency fund in place
then we're gonna pray about it and
discuss it then in the meantime what I
can do to help you is I can get you
through Financial Peace University we've
we've offered it and she refuses to
teach yeah so mom I can go ahead and
tell you that until you go through this
class we won't pay none of this ever
under any circumstances not because I'm
trying to sell the class okay but
because she needs to clean up her
freaking mess not counting this loan
it's good for her so I would tell her
listen you you can just say I'm not
gonna do it at all ever I'm not gonna do
it until baby step three be but I'm not
gonna do it at all ever if you don't go
through the class I'm gonna let you
wallow in it you made the promise in
your have to keep the promise I'm sorry
mom I love you but I'm not you and I are
not in agreement on this situation and
why am I so I'm gonna send you a copy of
the book by Henry cloud it's called
boundaries and you desperately need to
read it you will laugh and cry while
you're reading this book and you will
highlight virtually every page because
it reads your they read your all tea
leaves without a doubt thanks for
calling in